about distribution shift
great uh hi everyone i'm an assistant
professor at stanford i did my phd here
at berkeley so it's nice to be back
um
i guess more also as a kind of a means
for introduction um
i am i don't consider myself to be at
all a theoretician and in fact i do a
lot of experimental work including like
the experiments that you heard about on
the panel um working with
robotics
um and so here's some videos of some of
the robotics work that we've done
um today i'm not really going to talk
about robotics but um
the um a lot of the work that i do in
machine learning
is like
ultimately i think will hopefully also
help in really core robotics problems as
well
so um
as for some motivation i think that
we've seen some really impressive
advances in machine learning and deep
learning
and
there are arguably super impressive
advances as well in image classification
um machine translation
uh things like dolly two and so forth
but
um i think that in general machine
learning works well on the training data
distribution and there are a lot of
scenarios
where
the training distribution may not match
the distribution of data that the model
is seeing at test time
and so what i'd like to talk about today
is how we might handle this case where
this assumption is broken uh and
different forms of that sort of
distribution shift um when we might be
able to handle that distribution shift
we might not be able to handle it
and some of the assumptions that we
might try to incorporate into algorithms
when handling distribution shift
um so
i guess first let me give a few examples
of distribution shift that comes up in
kind of the real world so
uh
first in robotics
we often want to do reinforcement
learning from an offline data set
and there's a distribution shift between
the policy represented in the data set
and the policy that we're optimizing
and it turns out that if you don't
account for this distribution shift and
try to get a robot to close this drawer
here it ends up doing a behavior that's
rather dangerous and also of course
doesn't succeed at all at the task
um distribution shift also happens over
time so if you um i guess back in uh
2009 or so some folks at google were
trying to predict the incidence of the
flu from search queries
and
in their paper that was published in
nature they showed that they were
getting a 97 or 0.97 mean correlation
with cdc data
which is great that sounds really
exciting
but then a few years later they um their
model was predicting double the
incidence of the flu from search queries
because
things change over time
um and likewise if you look at the
perplexity of a language model over time
the perplexity will increase especially
for things like news articles and even
archived papers
so here are a couple examples of
distribution shift um to give maybe a
couple more examples those were kind of
distribution chips and reinforcement
learning and over time there's also
examples of domain shift or
subpopulation chip
so for example if you want to predict
the toxicity of a comet online because
maybe you want to make the the internet
a better place
if you collect a data set for this you
can get around 92 test accuracy
this sounds
pretty nice uh it sounds like your
system is maybe
pretty good maybe good even good enough
to deploy
but then if you look at the accuracy on
different subpopulations
then we see that the system actually
gets only 69 accuracy on non-toxic
comments mentioning the black
demographic
and this is
not only problematic from a fairness
standpoint it's also problematic if your
subpopulation of users changes over time
and as one more example in a completely
different domain if you are trying to
predict the activities of different
molecules
you can get around a 34 average
precision on test molecules from
training scaffolds but then if you want
to deploy this model to molecules from a
new scaffold
your accuracy or your precision drops
significantly as well
um
so i guess hopefully i've maybe
convinced you that distribution shift is
a problem that comes up in the real
world and it's a problem that we should
probably care about in the context of
machine learning
um if you're interested in these
particular kinds of data sets that have
domain shift or subpopulation shift i
and are interested in running
experiments on them i'd encourage you to
take a look at the wilds data set which
has 10 data sets that were informed by
domain experts on a wide variety of
different applications
it's also put together by pageway and
shiori and if you have any comments or
feedback on the um the data sets they're
really eager for feedback and to try to
improve it
great um so
now
now that we've talked about distribution
shift we need to
think about how we might address it and
i don't think that there's necessarily
going to be a catch-all solution for all
the different kinds of distribution
shift
in fact some kinds of distribution shift
are not even going to be possible to be
able to handle
and there's also different kinds of
distribution shifts so
very coarsely you can categorize
distribution shift in terms of covariate
shift which is changes in the
p of x label shift changes in p of y or
concept shift
um in this talk i'll focus on covariate
shift and label shift
and in particular i'm going to first try
to talk about some approaches that try
to address fairly extreme forms of
covariate shift
and if we have time in the second part
of the talk i'll talk about some
approaches for trying to address label
shift and also just get a better
understanding
of of the challenges that arise in label
shift
um and in the the first case we'll be
looking at both supervised learning and
reinforcement learning settings and in
the second case we'll look at long
tailed image classification
cool um so let's first start with trying
to build methods for addressing
covariate shift
and before i actually kind of dive into
some of the work that we've done here
i'll
briefly overview some existing
approaches for tackling covariate shift
so um there are two
high-level classes of approaches that
have been fairly successful in practice
the first class of approaches tries to
rebalance the data in some way
um and so the key idea here is just to
upgrade or up sample data points that
are underrepresented in your training
distribution
in the hopes that if your distribution
shifts then you'll be more robust to
shifts that make those data points more
represented
and this includes things like
distributionally robust optimization
um uniform class re-sampling and a
variety of other approaches
um so this is one class of approaches
that basically just tries to re-weight
the data
one other kind of broad category of
approaches tries to learn domain and
variant representations
and the key idea here is to
learn an underlying representation
inside your neural network that is
invariant to the domain such that when
you get data from a new domain or data
from an underrepresented domain your
model still performs well
and so this includes things like domain
adversarial neural networks and variant
risk minimization and so forth
so these different approaches they
in general they've worked fairly well in
practice and they can produce models
that are robust to spurious correlations
and to domain shift
but they also have some shortcomings so
they may require domain annotations they
may require you to know
what domain the data came from this is
practical in some scenarios it may not
be practical in other scenarios
especially if you don't know what
spurious attributes arise in your data
set
and second they'd also don't address
more extreme spurious correlations
so what exactly do i mean um actually
yeah before i kind of move on i should
also mention that
um all methods for tackling any sort of
distribution shift need to go beyond the
standard id assumptions uh
otherwise we're not gonna really get
anywhere beyond kind of what empirical
risk minimization can do
um and so i think that it's important to
have this keep this in mind and also
i think it means that it's not just the
solutions that are unknown it's also
like what sort of assumptions should be
introduced into these methods
when actually thinking about trying to
solve these problems
okay um so
now
in this first part of the talk i want to
start with an example of
a fairly extreme form of covariate shift
and we're going to start with a really
really simple example where we have this
2d classification problem
and we have two features feature one and
future two
and our goal is to classify between the
positive training examples shown in blue
and the negative training examples shown
in red
and then
there's going to be covariate shift and
in particular the gray examples are
showing
test examples with an unknown label
now in this example
we can note that there are a lot of
examples that achieve low training
accuracy
but they can't all be correct in terms
of accurately classifying these test
examples
and so we need to think about what
feature the model should try to use
and it's worth mentioning that this
problem is fundamentally underspecified
the training data doesn't tell us enough
about what the correct function is
and it's particularly underspecified
because there is distribution shift if
there wasn't any distribution shift
we wouldn't have a problem accurately
classifying test examples
okay um and also feel free to interrupt
if you have any questions in the middle
of the talk
cool
yeah
yeah so what i mean by underspecified is
that the the training data set doesn't
doesn't fully specify the correct
function we can't infer the correct
function
that achieves low test loss
just from the training examples
but but you always have that just using
training samples you cannot like even
with the iid assumption even if there is
no distribution shift
just using training samples doesn't tell
you anything about the test distribution
yeah that's a reasonable point i think
that the
there are certainly scenarios where like
in an iep scenario um
where there are multiple solutions like
you could like there's a solution that
um
that actually
like learns it kind of intuitive
solution there also could be something
just like special cases each of the data
points and so forth
um
so i guess maybe
um
[Music]
we can think of it under specification
in this case is just something where um
even with like fairly natural forms of
regularization we won't like we don't
necessarily recover
is it also the case that like
um in the standard iii assumption if you
had infinite data then the problem would
be
okay but in distribution shifts if you
have infinite data yeah it's like under
specified huge infinite data is that
like also yeah i think that's also a
good way to put it is yeah even if you
had infinite data it would still be
undertaken
infinite data from the training
distribution
cool um so
given that it's underspecified um i
guess well first we can think about a
few different possible solutions to this
um one possible solution is just to try
to regularize towards the correct
function if we know have some domain
knowledge about what feature that we
want them all to use we can regularize
towards that solution
um
this will a solution like this will
require domain knowledge you need to
know something about what the correct
function is and not only does it require
domain knowledge it also requires a way
to convert that domain knowledge into a
regularizer and that the second point is
very easy to do in this 2d example but
maybe much harder to do
in higher dimensional examples like an
image classification problem
um and so
this is not a a solution that
we
will we want to be able to basically
develop a solution that doesn't require
these two things
now an alternative solution would
actually be to try to learn multiple
functions so rather than having the
machine learning system
output just one function
it could actually output multiple
functions
and then
we would then need some sort of
disambiguation procedure to happen
at test time with a little bit of an
added knowledge in order to figure out
what the correct function is
and so in particular one way possibly of
doing something like that would be to
try to learn a bayesian posterior over
your parameters to try to basically
cover the space of possible parameters
but even something like this um doesn't
really scale well to deep neural
networks
um for example one kind of crude way to
try to approximate the sort of posterior
that works decently in practice is to
use ensembles and even if you apply
ensembles to this particular problem
you'll get um
functions that more or less look the
same that don't actually
cover the space of possible solutions
um and so
in general vanilla ensembles here are
going to show show very little
disagreement even on this toy data set
and it could even be much worse in
larger scale settings because of
simplicity bias or texture bias or
something like that
so
what we wanted to do in this work is we
wanted to figure out if we could
learn multiple functions that do
actually better cover the space of
solutions
and the way that we're going to do that
is we're going to try to learn multiple
functions but add a term that encourages
diversity
of those functions
and
it's challenging to
challenge diversify if you only have
access to the training data
and so what we're going to do is we're
actually going to try to diversify using
unlabeled data from the test
distribution
and so we're actually going to be
operating in the transductive machine
learning setting where we have access to
unlabeled test data during training
and with that unlabeled test data we can
actually train for the models to make
differing predictions on those unlabeled
test examples
and so um in particular we're going to
train for multiple functions this could
be like like an ensemble completely
separate functions it could also just be
a neural network with multiple different
heads which is going to be a little bit
cheaper than an ensemble
and
we saw that ensembles like vanilla
ensembles don't work and so
when we train for these multiple
functions we're going to optimize for
two different objectives first we're
going to train for all of the functions
to minimize training error
and second we're going to
maximize the disagreement between these
different functions on the unlabeled
test data yeah sorry
so we're thinking about the covariate
shift case right so if we already have
unlabeled data from the test set then
can't we learn the distribution shift in
some sense if we had enough data already
so if you have unlabeled data from the
target distribution you
um
you you do not have information about
what the covariate shift is but that
doesn't necessarily mean that you can
get a model that correctly predicts
labels such as an example that i showed
oh so we are not assuming that the
conditional distribution remains the
same
um so we are assuming that we have
access to the to the target distribution
p of x or p p test of x
um
the like one canonical approach to
solving this problem would be to use
like important sampling for example to
basically rewrite the data like i
mentioned before um in the case that i
in this particular example if you
re-weight you just don't have support um
you don't have your training data
doesn't have support over your test
examples and so approaches like that
won't be able to solve this problem
um so we have these two different
objectives that we're going to be
training our our functions on and
um in particular uh kind of intuitively
you can think of this as training a
neural network with multiple heads we
want these heads to be maximally
different from each other
and
we essentially want to push them apart
within the space of near optimal
functions on the training
near optimal functions that do well on
the the source distribution
um and
the way that we're going to diversify is
specifically considering the unlabeled
test the unlabeled target data and
encourage the models to make different
predictions on those unlabeled target
data points
specifically the way that we implement
this this diversity term is we minimize
the statistical dependence between the
predictions from one head and the
predictions from another head
and so this will encourage the model to
the model to make different predictions
on on these target examples because
it'll basically just encourage the the
two heads to be independent from one
another
um and this sort of loss you can
actually
uh compute in closed form for kind of
discrete cross-entropy distributions
yeah
if you try to maximize this agreement
then the two heads
are like necessarily dependent they're
like the
first set depends on
the second health because they are
disagreeing with each other
so um i guess so one thing that i'll
mention is so you could if it disagrees
on every single data point then they are
going to have a high correlation with
each other and we don't necessarily want
them to disagree on every single data
point because our target distribution
may still include examples that are from
the
that are from the train that are in the
support of the train distribution
um and so we found that a loss function
like this works better than something
that like just maximizes like l2 or l1
in terms of the predictions um because
of
uh because we don't necessarily want it
to be making the opposite prediction on
all the data
and
is that how you also
avoid them
predicting like
opposite labels and cancelling the
prediction of the ensemble
at the end
so in the end these two heads are used
as an inside the ensemble of the new
networks right and if you had tried to
maximize the disagreement
then the ensemble would basically cancel
out
um the two predictions
how do you avoid that
the ensemble would cancel out i don't
think she said that they're using
they're actually combining
oh do you have any
we haven't described the second stage
this is just the first stage so we're
using this to learn multiple functions
and i'll talk about the second stage
maybe we can take four questions on this
specific form
yes
so
um once we
optimize these two objectives to learn a
set of multiple functions
then we need to actually figure out what
function to use um one thing that we
could do is just do the typical kind of
ensembling thing and average the
predictions but we're not actually going
to do that in this case because
if we actually have an underspecified
problem then we don't just want to
return a single function we actually
want to figure out which function is the
right one
and so that's where the kind of the
second stage comes in where we actually
try to pick which function is the
correct one
um there's a few different ways that you
could go about doing this
the and we explored um
three of them empirically
um the first is just to randomly label
some of your test data points and then
select the head that's most accurate on
those test data points
and i guess i should mention that all of
these are going to use some sort of
supervision because as i mentioned
before it's kind of fundamentally
unspecified we need some more
information to actually
make it appropriately specified
um so this is one option although this
isn't
going to be that efficient because you
may need to sample
a fair number of data points and so
something that we could do to actually
require fewer data points is actually to
query the label
for the data point that you disagree on
the most
and
then use those labels to select the most
accurate head
and this should actually seek out the
the points that are ambiguous and allow
you to figure out what the correct
function is from that
so this is the second approach a third
approach is if you don't even if you
don't want to require any sort of labels
um you could also consider using
interpretability methods to just inspect
the different functions and try to
figure out what those different
functions are paying attention to
interpretability method is kind of an
open field and open problem in and of
itself but we have found in very simple
cases this sort of approach can also
work and this doesn't require any labels
on the test data
okay so that's the gist of approach so
the first we learn multiple functions
that try to cover this base of solutions
and then second we
uh
we then disambiguate and pick one of the
functions that we think is actually
corresponds to the true function
any questions
um is an author on it um
i
for the problems that we're going to be
looking at in our experiments i don't
think that they would work well because
you found it on like just
even like ensembles will learn very
similar functions um
i think that you can still see some
performance games um but i think that
this approach essentially uses some
additional assumptions that allow you to
get a kind of
a more accurate estimate
um so let's look at actually like what
this does in practice so
um first we can run this on the really
simple 2d example and
in this first case we just trained a
neural network with two different heads
and run it on the example shown here and
what we see is that we get one function
that pays attention to the first feature
and one function that pays attention to
the second feature
which is pretty nice to see
we'd also give it more than two
functions and so in this case we just
gave it
a large number of linear functions and
we see that it
covers the space of functions that are
consistent with the training data
um so those are kind of some some
visualizations on the 2d example
and then we looked at some experiments
on
um
on
more realistic data sets
so the first experiment that we looked
at is we wanted to construct some
examples that have this fairly extreme
form of under specification
and so what we did is we took some data
sets and constructed them to
specifically have a
complete correlation or a perfect
correlation between a spurious attribute
and the kind of core feature that you
care about and we want to construct
these data that should essentially be a
more challenging version of some of the
the sprayers correlation data sets that
are already out there
um and then the test data has imperfect
correlation or no correlation at all um
and so you're going to be seeing a lot
more of the the kind of other corners
that are grayed out that aren't in the
training data
um and then we're going to measure both
average accuracy and worse group
accuracy and what i mean by group is
essentially just one of each of these
quadrants so
a group corresponds to the kind of
a particular setting of the attributes
and then
in these experiments uh we'll take the
divdas method and we'll just give a
neural network with two heads and we'll
give it 16 active queries for
disambiguation
now
in our initial experiments we'll compare
to three different methods we'll just
compare the standard
erm standard neural network training
we'll also compare to two upwaiting
approaches jtt and group zero that
update examples with the highest error
or upgrade the group with the highest
error
i should note that none of these three
approaches are designed to handle this
very challenging problem setting
um in general they're actually
to our knowledge really aren't methods
that are designed to handle this sort of
setting and so these are just going to
illustrate how difficult the problem is
and so experimentally if we compare um
the performance on four of these
different complete correlation data sets
we first see that these prior methods
struggle as we would expect so
and in some cases they're doing worse
than just random guessing because
they're binary classification problems
um and in contrast uh kind of the
divda's approach is able to
provide very substantial improvements
over these prior methods
on three out of the four data sets it
gets more than 25 improvement and on the
fourth data set it uh it also sees a
large like an eight percent improvement
in worst group accuracy
now um these comparisons are not um they
don't have the same assumptions as
divdas they aren't using the labeled
queries and so
we could also consider giving a few
labeled examples to these prior methods
and see how they do
so
in particular we'll compare it to two
methods that could use these labeled
examples first is just to combine like
do erm but on a mix of the trained data
set and
n
minority examples from the test data or
from the target distribution
uh and then we'll also compare to
approach that was kind of recently
proposed in the paper which just
corresponds to running erm and then
fine-tuning the network on
and balanced and examples from the the
target distribution which are balanced
by group
um and if we look at basically how
these two methods and div is perform as
we increase the number of samples
labeled examples that we get from the
target distribution
um we see that
these prior methods require many more
examples than divdes because they aren't
explicitly trying to learn the the
functions that cover the training data a
priori
and so
um dividends is much more label
efficient and even if you have 128
labeled target examples um it's still
outperforming these somewhat naive
approaches for using these labeled
examples
and this is on the the water birds
completely correlated setting
um so the first experiment was on
completely correlated data
um in the second experiment we're just
going to look at these some of these
previously proposed standard robustness
benchmarks for robustness dispersed
correlations
and
one thing that prior methods have done
on these data sets is
they often tune hyper parameters using
information about the spurious attribute
and about the distribution shift and so
in particular
if you take these methods and tune their
hyper parameters with respect to the
worst group accuracy which requires
group labels they do a lot better than
if you tune them with respect to average
accuracy
and in particular we see that in the
kind of the first column the accuracy is
a lot higher than
in the second column
and so this means that they essentially
require access of group labels they need
information about what the spurious
attribute is a priority in order to tune
the hyper parameters
and this isn't something that we want
because these methods
or in many cases we may not know what
the spurious attribute is at the
beginning
um and we instead want to be able to
build models that are
robust without that information
uh in contrast we find that divdas
actually doesn't need access to group
labels so it performs well even if you
tune with respect to average accuracy
um
and to kind of dive a little bit deeper
into this if we look at the
performance for different values of the
hyper parameters
after tuning on the source distribution
the target distribution sorry if you
look at the performance in terms of the
source distribution accuracy the target
distribution accuracy
and the worst case target distribution
accuracy
for different values of the hyper
parameters we see that it's very kind of
the trend is very consistent
across these different distributions
and this means that if you essentially
because these look very similar this
means if you tune for one distribution
you'll also perform well on the other
distribution
cool um so essentially it's yeah less
sensitive yeah go ahead do you have a
sense of which
is in the majority class or is it
class on which the previous
the existing methods fail or like don't
do
yeah um in general it's typically the
minority class um and so where's chrome
accuracy is going to measure whatever
group it's doing we're set but in
practice we see that it's usually the
minority class
cool um and then the last experiment we
looked at was domination problems and so
we took the
one of the wildest data sets is the
chameleon data set where you're trying
to protect
if the cells are tumorous or not um the
label distribution
the the training data is from in
distribution hospitals and then
you hope to generalize to new hospitals
which is a pretty natural use case
because you don't want to necessarily
have to train a model for every single
hospital
um
there isn't complete correlation in the
setting again like the second experiment
and in this case we see we're compared
to different domain adaptation methods
that have been kind of proposed for this
particular problem setting that use
unlabeled data from the out of
distribution hospitals
and um we also see that devdis is able
to perform well on this kind of domain
shift setting so it isn't
doesn't only work on subpopulation
settings it also works well for domain
shift settings
um and compares favorably to these prior
methods
um so i guess the summary of of this
approach is instead of trying to learn
um
one function where we try to learn
kind of multiple different hypotheses
underlying the training data
and we do that by trying to minimize
training loss but also trying to
kind of
train for functions that make differing
predictions on the test data
um this allows us to handle under
specification in the data um and
allows us to perform well even if our
training data set is completely
correlated
um and also in scenarios where we don't
have group information available
yeah so for the
data experiments like the main chip or
cases where it's
not uh
perfect correlation like how many
heads do you typically find that you
need to use
yeah so actually in basically in all
these experiments we're just using two
heads um and so we
at least in these examples we found that
some heads works well
um
in scenarios where you have more than
one spurious attribute
or more than one source of variation
i would expect that more heads would be
helpful um
because you may need to learn questions
that pay attention to those various
attributes
um
at least in these days that's how you
looked at we haven't seen that to be the
case although you could certainly
imagine data like that i mean that's one
thing that we're looking into is like
can we handle those cases where we have
lots of various attributes
um and potentially even like here we are
learning a discrete set of functions you
could also consider learning a
continuous set of functions as well um
that's another thing that we're thinking
about right now as well
would you expect there to be like a
combinatorial exclusion of
necessary heads if you have more
attributes or is it expected you had to
pick up just like one attribute
combination
yeah it's a good question so um
i guess
i don't think we have a good
understanding for why this is the case
but we do observe that it seems to
generally learn to use one feature
rather than using a combination of
features
at least in terms of the first couple of
the first few heads that it uses
um
and so in that case
if you want the model to pay attention
to one feature rather than a combination
of features then you i think you would
probably only need
a linear number of heads in the number
of features
or in a number of sprays features um
although if you have a case where
ultimately it needs to use a combination
of features then you would probably have
neoconfident where a lever of heads in
the number of spurious features
um and you think that fortunately a lot
of data sets aren't going to have a
large number of spurious features in
practice
um and so that would mean that you
ultimately don't need that many um also
if we have a way to learn a continuous
set of functions rather than just a set
of functions
that would also make this more practical
um although i do have more and more
functions um the
um the disability phase will get more
expensive um you may need more labels to
disambiguate and figure out what the
correct function is
yeah if you wanted to extend this to
multi-label classification how do you
think you'll be able to enforce this
agreement between your
competing hypothesis
yeah that's a great question so so far
we've primarily looked at binary
classification problems um and if you
have multiple different labels then
um there's multiple different ways that
you can
make diverse predictions
um
i guess i mean one that you think that
you could do is just train a different
function for each label
um
and that's maybe somewhat dissatisfying
although
um
the
it's not i think it's not totally
unreasonable i think to do something
like that um
and then i guess we haven't really
explored it empirically so um i don't
have a good sense for if it would work
out of the box or not
yeah that's a great question so um we
found this sometimes helpful to add a
regularization term and in particular
what we did is we um
we just regularized the
marginal label distribution of the each
of the heads
to be the same as the empirical
p of y
um and so in particular if you um
one kind of
one instability that can happen is it
can just decide to like
for one head just label everything
that's unlabeled as like one and label
and the other head labels everything is
zero and that's an effective way to
diversify on the unlabeled examples
but that is that differs from the kind
of the label distribution that you see
in
the training data you don't you don't
see such like not everything is labeled
zero in the training data and you would
also expect on the test data
um that not everything would be labeled
to zero and so we added a light
regularization term to encourage
the the predictions to follow the label
distribution of the training data set if
you have any knowledge about the target
label distribution um then you could
also incorporate that knowledge
um we found it wasn't super sensitive to
this regularizer um and so if you set it
to be
different label distributions as long as
it wasn't like all zeros are all ones um
it seemed to work well we also see that
even without the regularizer it also
performs pretty well
it was good
um so yeah it's it's it's not
like
i i would not be surprised if some of
these baselines were getting zero
percent on worst group accuracy and
indeed we see erm is going to be seven
percent on water birds yeah uh but that
just means that it's paying attention in
this case the water bird status that
you're trying to protect the foreground
bird and the spurious attribute is the
background it's relying on the
background and the worst group um yeah
it's just pretty on the background that
it will get zero percent um so it's not
yeah i definitely am not surprised that
um
that it can be close to zero to some of
these cases
um
i
i guess i'm not sure does that answer
your question
yeah yeah that's uh
all right one other thing that maybe
i'll mention here is that um the one
thing that i like about this method is
that
um
in this inner toy example um
the
even if you add other dimensions to the
data set
it's only going to diversify
in the parts where you have unlabeled
test data
and so this means that you won't require
as you increase the dimensionality of
your data you're not going to require
more and more heads um you're only going
to require more heads and so far as your
training data distribution differs from
your test distribution
i think this property is really
important because we often do have high
dimensional data and i think this is one
of the reasons why a method like this
works well and methods that try to learn
like bayesian posteriors for example
don't work well because they're trying
to learn things that are diverse along
all all possible dimensions of the data
yeah
experiment
so to make sure i understand this
you do also have access to these test
points rather than like in this part of
the space
yeah exactly so yeah the test data
points aren't visualized here but we do
have access to them
and we only have access to that label
could you use this method to like detect
distribution chips that are
meaningful
yeah absolutely so we haven't run
experiments on this so it's like
anything i say here will be speculative
but
um i think that i certainly could see a
method like this being used being used
to detect this reason of being able to
detect experience correlations um
because if it's able to diversify
then
then that means that there is a
distribution whereas if it has
if it struggles to diversify then that
would suggest that there isn't a
distribution chip because it's a lot
harder to diversify on these examples
when you also have to uh minimize
training here than this to diversify
these examples
and that's that we haven't read
experiments specifically on that so
um
we'll see what happens
yeah so uh i'd like to
so about your comment about
like the diversification of bayesian
posterior could it be
the property of the
linear classifier so the linear
classifier has a mean seeking property
right so as you go away from the mean
the classifier is
more more uncertain so if you can
actually quantify the systemic
uncertainty of
the the classifier maybe you could
obtain something like this from
patient posterior as well
possibly i could certainly see something
like that helping um
but i still think that the
by considering that by using the
unlabeled test data you don't have to
diversify nearly as much
um you only have to diversify along the
axes that the test data differs and so
if you had like
you basically just have a much narrower
thing that you're and there were um
space of functions that you're trying to
represent compared to a bayesian setting
but abandoned posterior when you have
high dimensional data and so
i needed that um that in and of itself
and they could make this a lot easier
than when you don't have a label test
data
yeah i noticed as well on this figure
i'm not sure if it's just in this figure
in your other experience as well but it
sort of seems like it converges to the
max margin classifier with respect to
the trading distribution and then
i was wondering firstly if that if you
think that seems to happen in general
and second then what do you think would
happen if you started with the max
margin classifier so you train the erm
and then how would you take that
um
how would you diversify that era now
because it seems like it's kind of
what's happening here yeah so we also
noticed this so that was the case of
linear functions we also noticed this in
the case of neural networks as well we
see that it kind of converges there and
then diversifies
um we haven't specifically analyzed um
if it does that in the higher
dimensional settings but we have
actually ran experiments like the ones
that you mentioned
um they're not in the paper but we write
experiments where we first just train
the network on the training distribution
and then we've just fine-tuned for
like a pretty short time period with the
div is lost and we actually found that
that actually works quite well and you
can even just like fine tune the the
heads
on top you don't even need to
necessarily fine tune the whole backbone
the features as well um and that's
something that i think is actually quite
a nice property because it means that we
don't necessarily need access to the
unlabeled test data right at the
beginning of training we might just be
able to first train our big network or
whatever and then do this little step to
diversify once we get that label tested
i was also wondering how you think that
procedure compares to also the paper you
mentioned of the training retraining the
last layer is sufficient like how we're
doing that sort of compared to what
they're doing
now so the reason why we actually ran
that experiment is we saw that paper and
we're like oh maybe we can do some like
something similar with this sort of loss
um and so
yeah that was that was i think that it
in some ways
i guess i mean those experiments were
are still somewhat informal we haven't
put them in the paper and they've been
fairly recent but
um in some ways i think they do kind of
confirm some of the findings from that
last layer retraining paper
and um they
[Music]
and i guess this is the paper that we're
talking about um
and i do also think that there's still
some benefits of the dividend method
over this other other paper um
because the uh well first it's more
label efficient
um at least on this data set and um
and it may also be used for like
detecting distributions as possible and
i'm sorry for having so many questions
if someone else has a question
but kind of a little bit more of a
philosophical question like do you think
that in non-eye settings
it sort of
reasonable in general to expect that
building on erm is going to give us
something good or do you think that in
general
[Music]
yeah um
i guess i
i do feel like the
well so i think that like i like the
idea of learning multiple functions like
it seems like under specification
they come up a lot in realistic settings
um
even if you can also have under
specification just because you have you
don't have infinite data as well
um and so that's something that i think
is completely different from brm like a
lot of machine learning just has this
assumption that we're just gonna learn
one function and
ship it basically um
so there's that um
i'm not sure if i have any like
insightful thoughts beyond john that
though
cool um
so
that's a summary of this um
now as a bit of an aside um
there's also a question of whether we
could try to do this for reinforcement
learning
um and the project that i'll talk about
actually this is an older project it
actually came before divis and was in
some ways actually some of the
inspiration for goodness but um
um yeah all kind of
talk about it now so
um in this reinforcement learning
setting we're gonna be looking at a
setting where
we have one training environment
and our goal is to go to generalize to
new test environments
such as we want this walker to run
forward
in the simulation and
we want to be able to handle cases where
it encounters an obstacle or there's a
force that is kind of applied to the
agent or the the joints are disabled
and um
kind of the
some of the intuition here is that
if we learn multiple solutions to the
training data set then some of those
solutions might work well out of
distribution
so
if for example our goal is to get from
the green triangle to the blue to the
sorry the green triangle to the red
circle
then if we for example encounter an
obstacle at test time
then one of those solutions still works
um in each of the two cases
um this is still like individuals is
going to require us to adapt our
solution set at test time
um but it gives us some kind of recourse
it gives us kind of a contingency plan
when we encounter these auto
distribution scenarios in test time
um now this is making a couple
assumptions first is making an
assumption that we can adapt with some
data in the target environment
and um second it's assuming that the
changes between the trading environment
and the test environment are somewhat
and kind of localized
formally
what this means is that the optimal
policy in the test environment
needs to also do well in the training
environment
um if this property holds then that
means that if you learn multiple
um kind of irrelevant solutions in the
training data set
then it should actually
one of those solutions should do well in
the test environment
um
cool
so there's this question of how to learn
multiple different solutions um
we're going to do something very similar
to devdis where we're going to train
a set of policies that all do well on
the training environment and we're going
to encourage those policies to be
diverse
um
it's important that we can actually
control which um which policy to use and
so in this case instead of using it
learning a discrete set of functions
we're going to well we're going to use a
latent variable to basically index into
the policy rather than just learning
separate heads
um in this case the blade variable will
actually still be a discrete latent
variable but in principle the same
formalism could apply to continuous set
of variables
um and then in terms of
uh actually getting these policies to be
good we can formulate a constrained
optimization
um and so specifically we can formulate
a optimization problem that looks like
this
where we are um
going to encourage the policy to be near
optimal
and we're going to try to maximize the
mutual information between the states
visited
it by the policy and our latent variable
and this is going to encourage the
policies to be diverse
in a controllable way because
um essentially you can well there's a
few different ways to look at this but
if you have high mutual information that
means that z is basically predictive of
the states that are visited and
um and also that the
states have high energy
um
cool and then in practice you can
there's ways to kind of
actually kind of massage this objective
into something that you can actually
optimize with the reinforcement learning
algorithm
um and then at test time once we have
this kind of
set of diverse policies that are indexed
by z
we can then just roll out different
policies with different z's in our test
environment
and then return the policy that performs
the best in our customer
um
cool
so we refer to this as structured
maximum rl um in the sense that we're
doing maximum entropy but specifically
um
in a way that is controlled by the
sedentary
um
in our experiments we tested whether
this method
of learning diverse policies can allow
us to be robust to different kinds of
obstacles perturbations and motor
failures
and compared to
just standard reinforcement learning
with software critic um
a method that only optimizes for
diversity and doesn't optimize for the
task loss
and also a method that is designed for
robustness which is called robust
adversarial reinforcement learning that
basically injects adversarial
perturbations into the agent during
training
we're in each case we're going to be
measuring five shot generalization and
we're going to look at basically what
five shot performance looks like
as we increase the
the distribution as we increase the
difference between the train environment
and the customer
and so for all differences we'll expect
performance to go down as we increase
the distribution shift
um
and so we do see that trend um i guess
in the case of a motor failure if you
don't see a time like that but then in
the case of the obstacle and
on the force perturbation we do see
sometimes that look like that
um and overall the kind of the approach
that i talked about before is able to do
better than this prior robustness
approach down in green
um and it also does better than only
optimizing the task objective we're only
optimizing for diversity
five is the number of test rollouts here
five shots yeah five is the number of
rollouts that you get in the
okay and why do you
think you don't see this in motor
failure
um
i think that well
there is it could be an artifact of the
simulation it could be that we're not
um
well so i guess with the motor failure
i was just saying that maybe we're not
um
like maybe we didn't pick a motor that's
like really essential to these
particular policies or maybe we didn't
have the motor fail fail for a large
large enough period of time
um the
it's possible also that the simulation
um we're using the joke as extended here
and it's possible but it just didn't
have too much
trajectory in z but rather between each
and
each state
so it's kind of like
is it correct you think of it as
partitioning trying to partition
the state so
depending on zero
completely you know different set of
states for every yeah so it'll hurt you
to visit different states depending on
me um it's possible that um to solve the
task you have to pass through some
certain states and so it may not be able
to optimize that fully uh if it may not
be able to fully have them completely
disjoint sets of states
um you can also replace that with
trajectory as well instead of states
um although in those cases
yeah so
kind of the intuition there is um
it's sort of objective um there's a few
different ways that you can decompose
this the other way is to do h of z minus
h of g given
s
and
you can think of it as basically trying
to be able to predict z from the state
or put z from the trajectory
and it's actually if you give it a full
trade upgrade it can be very easy to
proceed even with a very small
difference
and so using the states here it's
actually a lot easier to optimize the
trajectory version of this um than it is
for the states and the state works a lot
better thanks
cool um we could also see some videos um
this is one of the cool things about
rl um so
here's uh the goal is to reach the the
goal position in the green dot um
if you just trade five different
policies with soft hypocritic you get
some policies that look like this they
aren't very diverse
and then if you give it uh you put a
wall in the way it understandably
struggles to get over the wall
um
in contrast if you um
train with uh this objective that tries
to encourage the policies to be diverse
um
when you get some diversity there's i
mean there's only so many ways that
cheetah can go from a to b but in some
cases you see it kind of goes more on
its back leg in some cases it's more but
in some cases it also flips over
um and in this leather case you can see
that the
flipping over side is actually pretty
effective
cool um so yeah the takeaway here is
that instead of just trying to use
machine learning to return one function
we can use it to learn diverse
classifiers and diverse policies that
allows us to very quickly adapt to
certain reductions
so
um like the latent space is relatively
low demand like the state space is
relatively low dimensional um we're able
to get this to work as well for like
sort of pixel value of observations or
is that
there's just so many of them that it's
right to define a good notes to mutual
information yeah that's a good question
um
so this work is from 2020 so it's from
2020 so two years ago and we're building
upon the diversities all you need the
diane method
and um we personally didn't try anything
with image observations
um i don't know of methods for learning
diverse skills that work
well with image observations i haven't
fully kept up to date on the literature
there but from what i've seen i don't
think i've seen anything that was images
maybe maybe proto oral maybe i can't
remember
if they have image experiments um
the
i mean principle though the ideas are
specific to what dimensional states um
but uh
yeah i want a good sign i think it's
probably a lot harder than the
observations um if you haven't tried it
what is the diameter
um
we're not always but like in a lot of
the environments it seems to do better
the further you cut from the training
environments
i guess
it seems like it's flat in a lot of
cases except for the top right face
yeah i don't have a good sense for why
that might be the case um
in the motor failure case
i actually hadn't noticed that before
i think that the it's optimized for just
it's not really optimized for the task
at hand and so we wouldn't really expect
it to be solving the task necessarily
um and so i suspect that there are just
it's um
there are some environments where it
happens to learn a skill that's good for
for that perturbation and there's some
environments where it doesn't so i don't
think that there's any particular
specific
cool um
all right so we talked a little bit
about covariate shift and also
distribution shift local distribution
shift in reinforcement learning um
now we have a bit of time so i'll talk a
little bit also about label shift
so um
one thing that comes up a lot in uh
in supervised learning settings is long
tail distributions where um
sometimes it looks like all yellow on
the curve on my screen it's green on the
big data and yellow and small data but
um
we kind of observe and practice that on
the long tail um
deep neural networks and machine
learning systems in general often
perform very poorly on the tail of the
distribution
and one hypothesis that we had for this
um for why this might be the case is
that
i mean first in general the tail has
less data
but in principle it should be able to
use the data that it has from the head
of the distribution in order to learn
better further
and so our hypothesis is that um
there are certain class agnostic and
variances that your model should um
should contain so for example it should
be invariant to lighting
um
and our hypothesis is that it probably
learns these invariants as well on the
head of the distribution but it doesn't
automatically transfer those invariances
to the tail distribution
um and we suspect that maybe if it did
successfully transfer these invariances
from the head of the distribution to the
tail then maybe it would actually be
more successful
i know what's kind of cool about this
hypothesis is that we can actually
run
um
experiments or maybe what noddy would
call simulations to uh
to test the psychologist
um
and in particular what we'll do is we'll
create a synthetic
data set
that has
these certain transformations in the
data set
and we'll train models and then evaluate
their invariants to this transformation
and in particular if we
if we construct this transformation
ourselves and have access to this
transformation then we should be able to
test and variance that transformation
and so in particular we'll look at a few
different transformations background
shading
um dilation and erosion of these images
as well as
rotation i guess in this case we're
actually the the long-tail data set
itself the original data set is from
this k on this um data set which is
actually naturally long tail although
it's going to be synthetic that we're
actually adding these transformations to
the data set so that we can specifically
test whether or not the invariance is
transferred
um
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to
measure in variance with respect to
class size and so
to measure invariance we're going to be
looking at the expected tail divergence
between the distribution before and
after the transformation
and we'll be measuring this as we
increase the number of examples
and if it was transferring our variances
successfully then we would expect that
the invariance would be or the value be
low for all num for all classes even
classes that have a small number of
examples whereas if it's not
transferring in variance as well then we
would expect to see kind of a downward
trend where we have worse invariants
for smaller classes and better
invariants for larger classes
and what we see is um both for
kind of
empirical organization and also for
an approach that
kind of resamples the data
we've seen in both of these cases we see
this downward trend where for the larger
classes it learns the invariance as well
and for the smaller classes it doesn't
learn these variances um and this could
explain
um this could probably one explanation
for why it may not uh provide these
models may not generalize well on the
tail of the industry
um
so yeah in general the evidence here
suggests that in variances aren't
transferred across different classes in
detail networks
um we also explored one way to try to
encourage the model to transfer
variances there are probably lots of
different ways to do this um
yeah well actually maybe i'll just skip
this part there's lots of different ways
to do it we use a generative model to do
it but there are other ways to do it as
well
um
and we find that it kind of improves and
variants overall
um and improves performance
cool um so to summarize um i talked
about learning diverse functions i also
talked about um
label shift and and variances
um
if you're interested in this
distribution shift i'd encourage you to
check out the wilds data set
i think we probably should go into the
break but i'm happy to chat offline
i think we come back at four we have a
ten minute break or something